there's a new twist in the case of a
Connecticut man charged with killing a
worker at a Caribbean resort a revised
autopsy raises questions about whether
cocaine detected in Kenny Mitchell's
system played a role in his death after
a fight with Scott Hapgood Errol Barnett
is following the case Errol what's the
corner in on corner in Anguilla saying
well we are working to confirm these
details but according to the New York
Times this revised coroner's report may
change the cause of Mitchell's death
citing that report the New York Times
writes that quote acute cocaine toxicity
could have been a potentially
independent cause of death now it
reportedly shows Mitchell's levels are
more than double what's normally
considered deadly although everyone
reacts differently CBS News has reached
out to the coroner's office for a copy
of this report but we've not yet heard
back if you remember Scott Hapgood said
he was acting in self-defense when he
got into this fight with Mitchell
pinning him to the ground in his hotel
room bathroom he claims Mitchell was
demanding money and threatening him with
a knife now we spoke with a hotel
bellman back in August he was the first
in the room when this altercation was
taking place and he said Hapgood was on
top of Mitchell and that Mitchell could
barely breathe he also told me that
Hapgood refused to get off of Mitchell
until police arrived
thirty minutes later now it's unclear
how this new report could affect the
case and the manslaughter charges which
is still pending against Hapgood back in
September there was a 5-day evidentiary
hearing but the results of that have not
yet been made public this case now
adjourned until mid November certainly
an another twist to the case there's so
many questions and for the victim and
his family they say he was he was gentle
we don't we would never expect for this
to happen but we need to wait for the
result of this case to see what the a
fascinating new details Errol thank you
very much